noah manoir il est éditorialiste pour le
magnet spécialiste des violences
policières
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt fonce alors selon pourquoi c'est
important de descendre dans la rue pour
dénoncer les violences de certains
policiers
alors je pense pas que ce soit
aujourd'hui important de décembre c'est
important de contester en fait la
validité de cette loi qui est une loi
liberticide
on va pas revenir sur tout ce qui a été
dit ces derniers mois sur le caractère
j'ai vu ce que nous de cette loi puisque
en fin de compte je pense qu'elle
résulte en réalité d'un compromis qui a
été trouvé entre les syndicats de police
qui ont fait pression sur le
gouvernement
et justement le gouvernement qui lui a
tout intérêt dans sa logique
ultralibérale de privatiser les services
publics dont une partie justement des
métiers de la sécurité et des missions
qui étaient alloués à la police
nationale
devon voit bien il s'agit d'augmenter
les pouvoirs de police des mers et des
polices municipales les entreprises de
sécurité privées etc général en échange
justement d'une d'un soutien
inconditionnel aux forces de l'ordre y
compris pour ce qui est des dérives et
des violences policières ce qui est
justement l'objet de cette manifestation
donc voilà dans un contexte où cette loi
vient d'être adopté par le sénat
alors on va parler de l'article 24 qui
était très controversé il a été réécrit
que pensez vous de la nouvelle version a
coûté en fin de compte je pense raïs
s'est soulevée ça fait partie du jeu de
stratégie politico finalement comme on
vise à faire adopter un texte de loi
je pense qu'on a excédé volontairement
sur l'écriture de l'article 24 dans sa
version initiale est en fait après
plusieurs mois de bras de fer entre le
pavé et l'exécutif ont fait quelques
concessions pour dire que finalement on
a écouté la rue
à la veille des élections et qu'on est
calme quand même sensibles à l'opinion
publique
mais je pense que c'est vraiment la
réalité ça change pas grand chose
c'était que mon les policiers jouissent
dans les fers je veux dire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui d'un soutien inconditionnel
de la part de l'exécutif pour ce qu'il
ya des violences policières
jallet il suffit de voir où se pencher
sur la question de la protection
fonctionnelle qui a été accordée aux
agresseurs de michel est clair et bien
d'autres fonctionnaires de police qui
nous peut être qu'ils sont suspectés en
tout cas d'avoir fauté mais dans les
faits si vous voulez ça change pas grand
chose mais en fait la réalité c'est la
privatisation des missions de sécurité
publique au profit justement des polices
municipales des mères dont les dotations
baissé ces dernières années mais
également des entreprises de sécurité
privées qui vont s'ouvrir à des marchés
publics
on va pouvoir armer un certain nombre
d'agents de sécurité et dans certaines
villes de france dans les grandes
métropoles
ce sont déjà des agents privés qui met
verbalisent les véhicules pour la
question des stationnements gênants et
c'est donc on voit même on est dans une
logique finalement de dilapidation des
services publics
ensuite mon quand on prend un petit peu
de recul on s'aperçoit que la république
en marche on fait un train de changer de
stratégie au regard justement cette loi
sécurité globale mais également de la
loi dite anti séparatisme sur
l'échiquier politique publique en marche
et emmanuel mâcon sont en train de
prendre un virage à droite en fait ou ne
pas dire à l'extrême droite et contre
toute attente
je pense que aujourd'hui la donne est en
train de changer c'est à dire que même
si les médias nous vendent un duel
macron le pen pour le deuxième tour des
élections présidentielles moi je pense
qu'il faut peut-être s'attendre à gérer
un bouleversement justement de cette
donne qui apparaît comme évident pour
beaucoup aujourd'hui on retrouvera
peut-être plus tôt j'en ai de mélenchon
au second tour pour incarner
rassemblement des forces de gauche et
peut-être enfin ce emmanuel macron lui
le souhaite en tout cas où
éventuellement marine le pen mais moi je
crois qu'il faut commencer à regarder
les choses d'un autre angle
pour ce qui est de la mobilisation et du
para et c'est à dire de passe aux
manifestations que compliqué aujourd'hui
dans le contexte qui est celui du
confinement de l'île de france notamment
donc moi je crois que d'autres façons se
mobiliser et je demande la nation
justement tous les auditeurs c'est
d'aller chercher massivement vos cartes
électorales
aujourd'hui un tel retrait vous voterez
pas en 2022 mais aller massivement
encore donnez vous pour aller chercher
d'un seul coup c'est d'être n'ai pas vu
l'ombre de semaine vos gardes électeurs
et si le ministère de l'intérieur
constate que 10 20 30 50 mille personnes
sont allées chercher leur carte
d'électeur en une semaine je vous
promets qu'ils vont voir les choses
différemment
par contre pour ce qui est de la rue
vous pouvez aller autant mauvais sachant
pas à grand chose
dans le pire des cas si ça excède un
petit pécule tirons dessus avoue dvd et
ça repartira comme depuis deux ans
noynoy remercie en tout cas pour votre
point de vue merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions j'en appelle coût est
éditorialiste pour le média et
spécialiste des violences policières
mercia